yo are we live one and a two and a live are we
live reject Nation reject to mundai you know
what to do die let us know if we are live John
we're going to do a thing in the beginning where
we're probably going to be sharing that Mouse I
don't do anything let us know if we are live you
know how we roll people confused you know how
we do let us know if we live we haven't had a
three of us one in a while what do we got what
do we got it's three people in the morning here
to watch some what's going on Diego eyes what's
going on people Isabella re all righty so we're
going to get right into it and explain why we
are doing uh trailer reactions live now this is
kind of experimental for us and when I say kind
of I mean a lot of last minute scrambling and U
mainly John figuring it out and we are all very
sleep deprived we are going to have a good time
yeah and see that's a good time that's a good
time now I feel it you earn you earned that
John so so guys thank you so much for being here
if you are here please go ahead leave a like on
the video we are going to cover the trailer so
right now as we are live The House of the Dragon
trailer has not yet dropped but supposed to drop
sometime whilst we are live so hopefully we hit
that sweet time frame where we can cover the boys
cover Fallout and then maybe by the time we were
done get some hot D we then we got House of the
Dragon out here on the Chanel um yeah so Amazon
and Prime video and HBO they like when it comes
to the trailer coverage they never let us monetize
and so I was like I'm always like spending forever
editing it just to get it unblocked and and then
you know you deal with these copyright claim stuff
like screw let's just do a live stream and cover
it live and just talk with everyone here do in
2023 they know that advertising is partly what
we do and they should let those live they always
eventually they always eventually Let It Go the
claim just so weird but but by the time the views
have stopped like thanks it's just so weird it's
not a movie it's like the ad we're doing your
job so with that in mind Shameless plug as always
guaranteed to have your question Read Super Chat
and streamlabs are welcome we never end a stream
without doing it and uh live streams are are
the playbacks on them are a little bit tough and
YouTube doesn't always recommend them and they
are often demonetized cuz this one especially
likes to say something that gets us in trouble
but this one especially is going to be demonetized
because of what we're going to feature in it so
super chats and all that very much welcome but
guys um I say uh thank you to so much who for
everyone who is here but we should just start
kicking this off right now and for those in the
playback there will be video chapters let's get
into it should we just kick it off with uh the
thing we all know the most about the boys boys
boys boys Bo do your thing man pull up the boys
all right it's time for the boys everyone in the
chat saying the boys I they're talking about us
or the boys we are all yeah let's start with the
boys trailer season let's do this thing hey look
oh we're all big and and and mighty all right so
we're going to P you be mindful of your leaning
Coy yeah forward or back or side just generally
let's just see what Ki has a habit let me just
block my I'm not going to have control over the
edit to help you here and so all right that's
your that's the framing size we have to have a
SL like again we have to put an oval because we
just don't want it to get blocked for sure it's
not going to be monetized this video but we
there we go not blocked that's a oh my God we
saw homelander spoiler I'm going to use this night
swim trailer really quick just to make sure that
y'all can hear I'm just going to play a couple
seconds let me know if y'all can hear good old
night swim what we need a vacon here all right
that's enough Universal especially doesn't let
us gets us in trouble all right all right all
if y'all could hear that just we just need we
just need confirmation you were able to hear that
yeah yeah as long as you guys heard that clippy
that means you'll hear this all right we're ready
for the boys it's time for the boys let's do it
let's watch the boys trailer all right ready gang
a one a two and a three and a three and we're off
Rome Greece that's Amica all democracies
fail because people are [__] stupid oh
yeah so excited to see them back but if you
crush the masses who builds your monuments
Tain oh he looks a little different yeah
the people will tear it apart themselves
you just got a nud on a little keep America
safe whoa Civil War then you get to swoop in
yellow's really striking be the one saving
it staright oh he's enjoying like Caesar
like ceser how often do you think of ancient
Rome you always got a is that a new black noar
je oh my God she's a vampire from Blade
2 black who wants their balls [Music]
crushed hair oh damn your team what's your
code name again the boys who came up with that
[__] ooh yeah yeah yeah got to update that
thumbnail the smile turning into Prime the
Cheshire Kat homelander file turning into the
Prime logo was so inspired that was amazing
Cheshire Prim Lander all right well we can do
something that we normally don't do John like I
said we're going to hog the mouse let's just put
the trailer up here while they go okay that was
oh I see what you mean all right we're going back
we're going back here we go and whoop yeah we yeah
yeah yeah all right so Coy if you want to interact
with the we can see the chat okay I want everyone
to know if I put looks real good I it's not going
to go on top of that sadly it is an election year
what a perfect time for the boys heill time all
right cool so it's goingon to look like that
all right got it yeah alrighty so go same let's
go through this a little bit here all right Coy
this is where you be get get to be a master we're
gonna break we're going to go through the boys
trailer bre Down live bit by bit and then we're
going to and thank you for all who have already
contributed to the super chats and we we will we
promise to get to all them first instinct a lot of
uh beautiful architecture in Roman inspired art as
they talk about the fall of Rome so for boing and
also showing Credence to him being like Caesar and
wanting to be yeah yeah but I think looks pretty
it looks really pretty also it's the back of
someone's head implying him getting shot like JFK
it's just now we're doing the real commentary yeah
guys please explain this VA video Blockbuster love
it's not playing what it's not playing what do
you mean oh oh that's interesting I don't know why
that is it isn't I want the I want the dialogue
all right I want to be able to hear what's going
on all right oh I'm G to just check something
we got a copyright cck did we yeah it sh right
away oh that's good all right now you can play it
that's hilarious well golly you tell us when you
want to pause co uh pause here uh so they're in
VA video which is obviously a play on Blockbuster
Video but I'm curious if this happens like in
between uh some of the stuff we saw in genv like
I'm curious if they tie in some of the elements of
him searching po right that's I'm saying like so
I'm wondering if this is like the first episode
like I think this is going to be really early
on while he's hunting and I think this this set I
think ties in genv just a theory sweet sauce P to
say he's going to remember them making love back
there because people are [__] stupid no I'm not
I'm smart smrt cuties but if you crush the masses
so the Starlite costumes uh you know ju deposed
with the the other is really interesting visually
but I'm curious what like causes this rallying
behind her like what does she do well she just
stands for like Liberty and well you saw stands
for like the moral side of thing there's like a a
woman's uh rights thing that they were that was on
some of their signs so I'm curious if there's like
a speech or something at the top of the season so
stuff and things in the chat saying this boy takes
place one month after genev that makes sense yeah
that makes a lot of sense so what's the Deep going
to do with this octopus he going to do some some
stuff I think uh we're going to see more hint time
we're going to see a little bit more that's what
I'm talking about we see a little deep there's a
little deep in the corner there's a little deep in
cor a little deep Corner little deep cor they're
definitely lovers cuz he's left a trib himself in
there all right good The House of the Dragon 2
trailer is out we're going to do Fallout after
this and we're going to do House of the Dragon
2 then we're just going to keep an open Q&A
going Jitter Bean Coffee Cup M you know what I
like about this trailer normally The Boys trailers
are are they start off with just so vibrant and
fun and kind of funky and so they leave with just
non-stop violence and the sexuality and this one
uh leans into the Menace of it all this really has
more of an ominous flare which is normally not
what I would expect for your boy trailer so we
have Starlight supports women and then we also
have keep America safe that's the sign I was
trying to really I have no idea what it's riffing
on thank you to all have been contributed we will
we promise to get to all the super chats thank you
so much what are all these red hats they're really
going to help out the stream today especially
already been copyright claim yet I can't remember
where I've seen a red hat before it seems so like
friendly and welcoming it's the Cincinnati Reds
they're all the Cincinnati Reds fans totally
totally I like how Starlight stuff looks like
Hamilton yes he does God bunch of Broadway Kids
wow I like the slight Obama uh Starlight face
broad Bama fight like a girl and well and the and
the raised fists together is yeah I love this like
she's horrified by the outbreak and it's what he
wanted well that's that's what I love about the
prospect of this cuz so much of the boys is is you
know the joy and terror is watching like oh man
how unhinged is homelander going to get in terms
of his life immediate power but I feel like one
thing that's smart at least about the prospect of
this is that they're raising the stakes by going
like oh the fall of democracy like there's going
to be unrest Just Between the regular people so
instead of Simply worrying about homelander coming
around and massacring you now you have like people
being radicalized like left and right also all of
this happening in broad daylight I like how this
trailer all takes place outside in the daylight
you see the the Smashing of the person at the
end like this is soups just being everything that
the boys have feared they'd become who is this uh
we haven't met her yet does anyone in the chat
know who this character is we'll wait sound off
people we're wait I don't think we've met her I
think this is new we're waiting in the chat to
see if I I mean obviously she's a new character
but if she's someone from the comics I wouldn't
know from the dialogue so far all right all right
well someone someone might who's holding hands
with ran bro that's Ryan's freaking Ryan that's
is not Ryan that shot isn't that this is someone
else's hand that's someone in a trench coat that's
a jump cut to make us think it is that's also on
the wrong side of the that's a man's suit it looks
like a man's suit maybe or unless it's uh what's
her name unless it's um could that be Marie's
sister some people are questioning if that girl
is Marie's sister um because she's a black girl
oh look out this this TR bomb with what is what
is her name the uh oh I can't tell firecracker
it looks like so that looks like a you know Fox
News correspondent for sure woo dude Jeffrey D
Morgan for you guys who don't know Eric kpy is the
man who Helms Supernatural and you know that is
obviously John Winchester this the father of s and
Dean Winchester he's bringing everybody in yeah
soon we'll get Jerry pad lucky yeah season six
boy and for all you SN heads that's Thomas Wayne
out man H me a flk it the Blade Two vampire the
New Black newr I'm very curious about him and I'm
curious if this is going to follow the we won't do
spoilers here but but there is a think that would
come around I didn't think because of how three
went they could but now they really could yeah now
especially I'm like oh are they actually going to
really attempt to to do that got to this looks
distur looks kind of like the effects yeah does
Starlight is so it's someone rebelling against
Starlight I'm sure here that's like the thing I
love it also I'm wondering if gen V is affecting
my guy damn that ragy squeal let out man we will
not spend as long on Fallout or sorry Fallout I'm
excited for Fallout bro daylight team what's your
code name again the boys who came up with that
[__] dude Carl Urban and Jeffrey deg it's gonna
be so great oh man wait it's just crazy it's kind
it's I kind of get like that American Horror Story
Vibes flare because American Horror Story will
sometimes do that thing where they go uh very
topical with whatever whatever their season is
and I say topical like what happened this year
and with it being election year next year and
this follow election year it's it's it's very
very top very pointed but damn this this I have to
update the thumbnail with this image it's perfect
let me just take a little screenshot to update
the thumbnail why don't why don't we just show
the process on the screen guys you guys want to
see how it's done here all right guys so we got
to get to uh let's uh John what super chats did we
get right now we we we'll we'll R them off really
quick inste back up and then we will uh go to the
Fallout trailer and after Fallout and while you're
doing that John this is very experimental stream
I'm going to then we're making art because I heard
the house some people in the chat said the house
of the Dragon trailer's out and some people are
saying it's not out but I'm going to check really
quick do we have hot D sound off below also some
people uh are speculating that maybe black noir
is in a flashback but I think he's in the Pres
oh no I think he's in the Pres I think he ties
into the comic black nor I won't say what it is
oh co with his Comics good for you I also think
Invincible episode 6 is going to have a big Cameo
I think it's out guys oh wow so should we should
we should we still do this uh Super Chat yeah yeah
let's do it let's let's do the super chats really
quick all right let's go do some soups let's do a
couple all right here this is the first one from
raccoon shampoo thank you for joining us raccoon
I have live 10minute test thank you raccoon and
I have to go watch the new godzill I have to I'm
being forced to watch millus Oney was the first
one to tell me about it and uh yeah my wife and
I we are going to go watch that because she's a
huge Godzilla fan oh she's going to be so we got
to talk imediately after the stream got married
last year and at this time last year and I had to
uh I got hospitalized on the day of my wedding so
we are going to make up for it by going to watch
Godzilla thank raccoon shampoo they're going to
rush you to the hospital during we're going to do
this once at a time let's go back to the let's
do the Fallout trailer once raccoon is our one
live stream I thought we had like two super chats
and I saw we had a bunch and I was like you know
what let's uh we we're going to pick that up
later let's do we're going to do the Fallout
trailer right and then one more Super Chat then
we'll do House of the dragon and then it's just
going to be an open Q&A again this is going to
be one of the messiest live streams we've ever
done all right we are going back like it hit that
like sort of embracing it sort of embracing we're
back in Action you guys ready don't hear so
really quick before we do this um do you guys
know uh I I don't know Fallout at all I know
wton Goggins I've played in Fallout it's been
a a minute but I played Fallout 3 a good amount
and uh you know and fallout shelter it's a big
open world game it's a big game it's not like
a linear plot no I've never played fall no you
explore the Wasteland boy okay interesting yeah
you're you're as I recall part three like you're
searching for your dad or whatever there is a
plot but you can do like three why don't you
play one and two first uh because Fallout it's one
of those games where like each generation it gets
rebooted like yeah you can follow all the lore
but like there's New Vegas there are different
each pocket of the Wasteland that you're peering
into kind of has its own a generation in terms
of like oh we revamped the tech and it looks
better and all that stuff but also I don't I
don't think it's one of those games you can
be a completest but it's not like oh you got
to play part one to understand part two you know
all right so chat are you guys excited now I've
never played Fallout are you guys excited for this
Fallout show we we got to know if we're if we're
going to like it or not before we form our honest
opinion I'm actually excited to watch something I
have no yeah prior basis in I just got to follow
whatever people in the chat are saying first they
say hey Christian unpronounceable always here
alrighty so uh yeah we have no I I don't know
anything about it um but let's see what goes on
all right let's try out this is going to be for
John who has some familiarity and Coy and Greg
who have no familiarity yes I know Michael tesler
who's usually our Star Wars now he's played all
of Fallout he's a he's a huge huge Fallout fan so
I'm like do we do that thing where where I bring
him on but I'm like but if he knows it too well
will he ruin the show anyway that kind of watching
it's a good game for being like Oh iconography but
it's not necessarily the kind of game where you're
like I played it so I could spoil the whole thing
for you all let's check it out let's see what's
going on cool here we go a one a two and a three
John it's not playing again all right it doesn't
seem to be working come on John you know it's
great about live you didn't spend hours working
on this last night every time we live stream we
discover a new random ass problem one two and a
three hey it's play in the vault 33 is a thing I
recognize I know that I've lived a relatively
comfortable Life The Vault costumes stop Mercy
oh it's her I like the cinematography a lot
so far it's got some ABS in it step into the
Wasteland oh Jonathan Nolan oh yeah buddy
to go home now I'm in okay Vault dwellers
are an endangered species yeah that's
a huge [__] you would be willing to
do what it takes to survive a p classic
tumble weed effect I love how she was
so dis by the T we nice if you insist on
staying then you will have to erson hello
Zep I'll give you that one Amazon I'll
give it to you all right they got jokes
okay me they threw down for the visual
effects that Terminator Salvation there
is a lot of different oh that awesome
like the armor oh [__] yeah I like the
ironic humor guy that's that's definitely
some Fallout the humor yeah there's an
irony the ghl that's Walton go the
ghoul why does he look like Deadpool
looks there's a yeah we we'll
talk about oh shoot oh so it's
like an apocal or Western oh yeah can we
cover this this looks amazing The Moldy
one Cyclops Parell oh parns looks
great and Kyle girls this C is
amazing oh zombie bear wa cocaine Bear
Went dark e the fingers I have no idea
what's happening but I I love this so much
uned Walton goggin before yeah for the big
one oh my God is this La it's the Griff
Observatory the Griffith Observatory right there
yeah yep did some of them take place in in La
hey rag where's the nuca kid yeah I think there
is yeah music's great Jonathan Nolan means
is gonna be written like where's the nacac
cola kid he he'll show up who's the nuca kid he's
actual video game film souls in 2000 says in the
track yeah uh nacac colola it's it's probably
seen him he's the little happy blonde guy with
the thumbs up there's definitely like an irony
in this world for sure that was a great trailer
like that was really good yeah you've seen he's
a little thumbs up boy oh yeaha kid dude that was
a solid trailer I'm excited yeah let's bring it
back let's bring it back John you pay attention
to the chat all right guys we're goingon to look
at House of the Dragon in a little bit that is
that is my reaction the whole time like I don't
know what's happening but I love it for a variety
of reasons um one I'm I I'm a I was a big fan of
the TV show Westworld I've seen every season and
Incredibly disappointed that it was uh it didn't
get a finish it had one season left and it didn't
get a finish off the its storyline and uh and
I get a lot of that flare here obviously I feel
like there's going to be some obvious things that
people Riff on or or see this and go hey it kind
of looks like this so yeah you do got some stuff
that kind of has that Mad Max flare to it um but
yeah a little bit of West world meets Mad Max I
love the ironic sense of humor in here I think the
visual effects were really solid what is Walton
Gog is he like a ghoul or something what's the
ghoul yeah uh basically there's like a a race of
basically once all the bombs go off and stuff like
that there are these people who are like heavily
irradiated um who kind of take on basically they
look all you better hurry it up joh they look all
zombie like and deformed like that and actually
some people are winging online because he doesn't
look as disgusting as they have in the games this
nose thing is pretty [__] disturbing to me well
yeah but in you know they're more they look more
overtly like zombies and less like Deadpool in the
games uh but yeah they're irradiated people who
also I think kind of absorb and can kind of power
up off of radiation uh now you know post I also
got Book of Eli Vibes apocalyptic Western yeah
absolutely and uh and yeah there are big creatures
and and irradiated bugs and stuff that are around
and yeah you got to go on all sorts of different
quests and side quests and stuff so who's our main
character is it the girl it's you in the game I
played you you create your own character and then
the game begins with you being born in the vault
I know who's our main character in the show is it
this woman it's this woman yeah who's this woman I
don't know why is she so terrified of this tumble
weed I think it's just movement like she's she's
never been in there she's like letting the tumble
weed pass as if she's going through traffic she's
like playing frog I would let it pass who knows
it's got somewhere to go clearly it's on its
way somewhere interrupt the tumble I forget what
this actor's name is Michael Emerson okay but for
him to have to be we will get to the house of the
Dragon trailer thank you guys for letting us know
yep um perfect timing we [__] time the [__]
out of yeah Saturday chaos but for this having
that big like mystery what the hell is going
on better narrator for exposition to come in
and be like I'm spooky over the fire yeah totally
I love the two shipping joke I just want to give
that a good credit again I I mean I loved it for
someone who does not know Fallout this makes me
want to now okay chat I'm asking the chat right
now should I play the game like actually play
the game and then watch it or should I just go
in blind because part of me just wants to go in
blind so I want to go in blind I'm enjoying not
being part of a fandom I like watching something
I love the symmetry of these shots so much yeah I
mean this looks like a really fun show joyous it
looks like they had fun making this depravity it
looks like yeah exactly depravity is a great word
for like Bleak butun but hilariously ironic like
like really dark like Nuka kid that seems like
the tone like I I only know that image yeah no
there's definitely like a humorous irony because
you're also living in a world where people are
used to this so there's like the whole day-to-day
mundanity of being in the postapocalypse I
also want to see La as even more of what apoc
grew Vault doesn't know what a there's a lot of
emphasis on this tumble weed people people are
saying go and blind and I do think it's one of
those games where you can do that because like
if you play the game you'll get the flavor for
like what the world is but it's not like oh I
need to refresh on some story or whatever so like
I feel like watching the show this looks faithful
enough that you should get the gist all right
John well okay so now that we have done that
we are let's John Let's people are saying play
Fallout 4 Fallout 4 is the main one recommended
let's go let's read one more Super Chat thank you
guys who have contributed to the super chats and
uh I don't know if we got any streamlabs but this
this stream is already demonetized so so that's
the only way much a seg waiting happen appreciate
it but uh yeah if we can uh just read it just read
at least one let's do one let's least one and then
let's go to House of the Dragon we'll go to House
of the Dragon can't wait I love that show so much
get some hot D get some hot D I like that show
Dragon hope you're enjoying Godzilla minus one
raccoon shampoo oh and thank you for correcting
yourself less than 10 minutes till hope it was
a good time or is currently being a good time
Cody Bishop Greg why don't you read that while I
download this trailer download the trailer we're
going to get the trailer for hether right there
in our notifications um Cody Bishop is saying
hey guys much respect do you play video games or
what other Hobbies you all have besides movies and
TV shows and how long have you been friends do you
even game bro well I've been uh after covering the
cut scenes for Spider-Man I have been officially
planning which is allowing me to really go through
like all the other random levels and side missions
and such and like I have to play in weird chunks
so like just the other night it was 1:15 a.m.
I said Google set a timer to 2 a.m. so I could
just P like I got 45 minutes and I and I've been
having to play it like that and I finally got to
black suit Spider-Man after like a month and a
half I could only play in like 45 minute chunks um
sporadically yeah sporadically it's very sporadic
like schedule's like all over the place so yeah
but I I wanted to actually get my my hands on
it and which has been really fun and and they
and yeah those cut scenes did live out quite a bit
of stuff actually I uh I'm gonna be playing Miles
Morales soon because I don't have a PlayStation 5
so I saved miles for my phone so I have not played
miles yet so my fomo is going to be quenched with
some Spider-Man and then uh I play Need for Speed
like I'm a big race car game and I haven't played
I haven't touched a cons console controller since
Spider-Man Need for Speed is the best video game
I love those so much uh but I haven't played since
Spider-Man so I'm going to play that and then
uh we've known each other five six years have
we I mean we didn't really start like kicking
like etal yeah but like we we've like seen each
other in passing but we weren't like AC we weren't
friends you guys you guys were sort of buddies and
then way to downgrade our lovey pretended to like
you he just wanted to get to me is what he said
no wonder I can never you on I was like I can't
talk to Greg without joh he was always talking
to John I was always like oh yeah yeah should do
something together man GRE watching us talk is
Greg watching finally I found somebody this over
here he's working his charm just side eye flirting
I played the long game and it worked it's okay we
got hot D I'm going to manage these rejects just
to get to Greg all right guys all right guys let
just keep increasing them copyright claims let's
do it another hot d one two three oh what short
oh okay I'm sorry here we one two one two three
I I feel like it's not allow everything's
got to fail the first take is happening joh
John remember remember everyone's name John all
right I remember everyone's name here we go 1 two
three errors were made in the hours following
King vas's death King visera Tor the wall
bef many will die oh my God I got ni oh
man and the Victor will eventually Ascend
the throne God this looks great let's go
there is no war so hateful to the gods
oh here we go there's a war between
Ken true that oh those dragons facing
off and no war so bloody as a
war between dragons the anguish
[Music] yeah rematch yeah or
not rematch Vengeance match not
rematch yo yeah she' be going after him after
what happened to her son right I think that's
what the commentary on the dragons is about it's
not actually about dragons it's they they refer to
themselves as Dr play it again I want to watch it
again all right I want to see in family fighting
it's like it's such a weird conversation in my in
my house because was my wife has read the book yes
and she's read all Game of Thrones and I hav't
read any of it so I'm like this is all new for
me I don't know what's going on this is fantastic
I'm like other than I know that some ties in a
game Thrones these blonde people relate ancient
history targaryan this is one where like I avoid
breakdowns for it and [__] because oh I love the
mystery of not knowing oh yeah let's go let's go
I want watch it again the hottest thing but I do
love the show were hours following King maser's
death I'm a Dar the wall be the scope of this
show is always I feel like they got this done so
fast yeah I feel like we just watched season one
yeah it's R there was a strike in every every show
taking come back they were able to work past the
another right that's how it feels so fast everyone
else paused here everyone's thanking their lucky
stars so hateful to the Gods is our second time
watching the TR for anyone just tuning in by
the way so we're talking a little more look at
that this feels like so much more ethereal this
scope is so enormous and no war so bloody as a
war between dragons what a way if this like more
mournful and sorrowful this time yeah it almost
feels like going from Game of Thrones season 1
to season 2 yeah something I'm so excited for
like getting her revenge is this scope cuz yeah
the ending shot was just on her right yeah after
learning about what happened to her son yeah at
least as I recall oh man that was greatting but
a just the tone of that alone oh man I could just
watch this one over and over again it's yeah it's
a great tease because it's got so much mood but
it also it seems like a kind of trailer that is
sprawling across a season it's really only got
one line like the dialogue is one little monologue
which I love is just a little bit of exposition
well and it does feel at least to me like that
that feeling of like okay you have like it was
in Game of Thrones season 1 like you've got all
these mounting stakes and tensions and whatnot but
things are still kind of contained and then you
get to this ending point where it's like oh great
things are going to pop off now and yeah look at
this dragon with the W uh on the uh I I don't know
if these details were in the dragon before is guys
it looks more I'm afraid to ask questions in the
chat right now because in the book each one of
these holes has specific explanation that's from
the third book that's from the four B I'm honestly
a little afraid to look at the chat at this moment
hopefully you guys are cool just tell us how hot
you thought the D was yeah oh yeah I know it's
just like there was so much loss in the last uh
season seriously it span so much time and you're
watching like lineage rise up and and people who
have like these real personal vendettas while in
the midst of War I just and we had so much trauma
this is like you Vengeance I'm excited to see all
the rage come out yeah no it feels like a real
act two for a season two you know well I mean the
battles like look at this shot god [__] amazing
shot that's a desktop way and on your guys's
Z because we had to crop it in it looks even
better you can't even see the dragon don't even
worry about it look at that little edge of a shot
there you go there you go look at your new phone
background there's some dragons gorgeous there's
some dragons Oh What a Beautiful that hot D I
want to ride a dragon oh dude this yeah this looks
feels like it feels like a dream yeah that has it
also has that like especially for her it has to be
and I noticed there wasn't they surprisingly did
not lean into Damon yeah I I figured it' be very
Matt Smith heavy or anime super villain guy heavy
but instead it's just touch oh what is his name
he's such a great character Aon I think yeah he's
so fun to watch well that's the thing is that this
feels like um whereas the first season is very
focused it feels like this is going to broaden
out the board and be like okay now everyone in the
realm is sort of responding to this and there's
like yeah going to be huge disputes over lineage
and power and and you know who gets to rule and
blah blah blah I love how Matt Smith just gets to
be so like pensive and like authoritarian yeah I
love this character for him so much all right
guys let's pull up the chat dude that was some
hot D thank you we got let's readjust here okay
oh goodbye legs goodbye the chat we're going to
readjust the framing and all that all righty let's
do that thing in a world of pure trailer reactions
we're gonna demonetize for John's song he's gonna
copyright shal shalam La all right hey we're back
heyy hey am the chat not a John amond amond Aon
amen amen my bad thank you thank you there you
go figh of we already covered Fallout you're
late you're late Dei Just Tab backwards this
is one of those shows where every episode Hot
D I got to like relearn everyone's don't worry
guys we're hey Michelle uh we're already going to
be covering um we're already going to be covering
uh Reacher season two so excited going to be doing
a trailer reaction for Reacher where it's coming
out shortly I watch Reacher one yet dude I hate
you let's catch up on some supers uh thank you
guys so much who have contributed to the supers
because uh yeah stream very much demonetized yep
is there any other trailer we should watch uh
from another major Studio to demonetize well
just like should they fight the copyright claim
Gozilla versus Kong is tomorrow oh so we'll be
covering that yeah that's exciting all right what
do we got here in the all right I'm about to go
see the new a24 movie with Nick Cage I've heard
that as good dream are you seeing Godzilla minus
one first or after have you seen that clip of uh
after what are you seeing both are you doing like
a double feature for what Godzilla and dream
scenario I was asking you said youill oh you
reading I was like I thought you were talking
about your day hey Charlie Fernandez good to
see you in the chat poo Pride dreaman Zilla can
you refresh it I'm not going to refresh it ever
I don't refresh stuff you refresh stuff you're
fresh MK1 is dropping a new gameplay soon I am
always is that game out we we've come this yeah
but they usually do like add-ons and stuff yeah
DLC koi come on downloadable Co tent yeah every
knows I know games there's so many trailers this
morning did did we do Cody Bishop hey guys thank
you so much for being here you know honestly like
it's so it could be stressful like when you're in
a rush to assemble the this morning was chaos like
putting them together and all that stuff it could
be a little bit I mean putting the stream together
enough was was already like a little bit hectic
and you know just the idea of like doing like
three trailer videos stack to stack to we got Dr
Who coming out more efficient oh yeah there's so
much happening today and so to uh but this is this
is super experimental for us on such a big trailer
day and I want to thank everyone who's here uh
and I I think this was really fun all the chaos
that led into being able to pull this off honestly
it's actually been a lot of fun so thank you guys
for being here absolutely Super Chat we're not
we're not used to this side of it whereas like
I know other people are a little bit more more
better acquainted at doing the live [__] than
we are so we're trying you guys all right did
we do Cody Bishop we we did we are at Matt of
all trades thank you so much Matt of all trades
good name love being a part of this live stream
we love having you you three are the Dream Team
K keep kicking ass guys thank you so much thank
you apprciate the love M you keep kicking ass you
got a good icon there the Jack of all complim A's
always in our stream so in case you guys don't
know we just covered the three trailers uh for
that we that are in the title we have honored
the title yes the boys fallout hot D yeah now
we are just doing an open Q&A for it but if you
guys are just tuning in you guys can go back
and watch it uh if you'd like we'll be here we'll
be here we'll be waiting roads of teal thank you
for being here we appreciate you watched Godzilla
minus one yesterday great movie hope you watch it
I am vowing today to never watch another Godzilla
ever again out because of how good they are shin
Godzilla that's enough for me uh well yeah I mean
you we have a deal going oh my God what a generous
Super Chat you see that it's a big stress relief
now we can pay now it is okay now we're good we're
good now we can relax all because spread my legs
out there it is we get to manspread now man spread
baby we earned it we get to man's friend now now
we do I was crossing it we be adults and proper
before uh Godzilla minus one is one of my top
of the year um I was lucky enough to host the O
Premiere but what was cool was before the premiere
I had to see the film direct questions to ask the
the gentleman who made the film and uh I watched
it at um like a private screening in this giant
circular room where they were mastering the atmos
sound so I watched the film like by itself with
no one and uh I got to hear the sound master and
then I got to watch it with an audience and like
see how they em reacted to it it was really it was
a really special experience and the film is one
of my favorites ever and probably is my favorite
monster movie of all time can you guys hear John
and I how'd you do that John oh was right there
that you just got to highlight the one I didn't
know that's what I was trying to find out like
which button is it guys yo can't wait to get to
you there buddy this is how the sausage is made
yep you're seeing it now I tried to Vamp As Long
John and I were like let's let's try not let's try
not to let the the audience here joh and I like
I don't know just you saying I I can't hear you
this is like a football like where they pick up a
microphone from this was a bad IDE maybe we should
just say it into the chat there it is I have a I
have a fun game you can hear them in the pit crew
I have a fun game for how to read these though so
yeah we we have um like here at the channel
like obviously we do movie reactions here um
a lot more now so we kind of have we kind of have
to pick and choose sometimes like all right who's
going to get to watch us in the theaters and who's
going to be able to watch us here so and I know
like there's channels like blind wave for example
where they seem like they never go to the theaters
uh sometimes they do but more often than not
it seems like they just wait and but here we're
kind of we usually just only keep three people on
camera at most but we and so it's a little bit of
a pick and choose game and because you and Andrew
covered Shin Godzilla I get to go to the theaters
to watch Godzilla minus one covered no fair now
I'm excited to cover with Andrew I'm looking
forward to that react there will be a mayi get
ready all right now read it whoa May R of do it
John all right all right fine demon laughing my
run nari when is Godzilla XCOM trailer releasing
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow it's coming out
tomorrow at 130ish I think is their panel so
look out for what else is tomorrow it's Sunday
the the Lord worshiping the Lord is day of rest
day of rest our Doctor Who reaction goes up
going to debate with half the audience about
our opinion on about when Doctor Who got woke
yeah just point on the timeline when this out
yeah I agree with you River Rock the show
that welcomes people on hi Tamil oh there
it is quiet there I try to act like now now
I'm just so um unfazed by how how chaotic you
can send this to sponsors and be like we're
a well yeah we know what we're doing guys
professionals look like check out this live
chat here here let's Weir are the definition
of throwing spaghetti at the wall see what all
right we're going to want to see more that's a
great question first watching this live stream
we're going to read Ana's uh one right now here
we go uh hi wanted to stop by and say miss and
love y'all that's for you you get the cookie V
felt it Ana we love you very much shouts out
to you in TAS I get what the problem because
normally it's just the two of us it's just
two at a time so so fitting all three of us
on making yeah the ratio is a little bit odd
yeah okay I was like why does this look weird
that makes sense this is in a special
format now it's letter box yeah all right
yeah uh you know we should just have
like super bright visuals constantly
changing in the background here's what
I'll do I mean we could put a video in
the background [__] what if we just
play something back to who there's just
Mt Matt has joined us there you go now
they're just going to exist underneath
us there we go here well there we go kind NE
that's fine I love how people will come and
be like hey jabby did this so you should do it
jaab I don't do anything jaby your brother does
it you have to no this is how it works Morgan
Han thank you I love you too thank you Morgan
Han for being here I miss love y' that's for you
robot so intense uh we missed theow down sometimes
too I miss it I did I pitched uh I told um I I
told Christian I was on their the the his pod
his patreon show yesterday or two days ago and
Christian wait when was Monday today Saturday
today is Saturday oh my God it was not yesterday
that you did days ago yesterday Monday so I was
I was on um and I told him like you know a long
time ago I had a movie idea for the Schmo down
to do like a YouTube movie like it would just
be on YouTube and and I'll tell it here right
now I'll try to make it I'll try to pitch it in
one minute so the idea was that like uh we were
going to John and I were going to go do a match
and then I complimented Christian's wife about
how hot she is and then he actually didn't take
too kind to it so then he sets me up for failure
during the match we're fighting against Jay
Washington and he's like so in jeno and chain
what is the most used word that CA controversy
and I was like uh say it yeah and he's like but
you have to say the actual word or else you don't
get the point this what they're saying you get the
actual word I'm like I can't say it you going
to fail the match and then I say then I just
get cancell but then I wake up and it's the same
day again and so then I'm living a Time Loop for
theog day Brown Hog's day but like an nword Loop
of cancellation yeah it'll be fun uh don't worry
we're not going to cover this we look we went
in totally blind for Reacher season 1 so we are
actively going to avoid reer season we're going
Blinder we're going to wear blindfold watching
re Reacher season 2 comes out in uh just in
a little bit a little bit later so uh we're
going to like next week or two weeks from now and
they're going to be preparing three episodes so
we're just going to wait uh for that to come out
uh but yeah we will we're definitely be covering
the Fallout show th% I'm so looks great fasty
says Greg should be white I like to yes beautiful
beautiful work on that Greg you haven't you been
told that I am half white yeah but you more whiter
Italian counts as as white fasty says more white
yeah yeah you should be all the way uh I covered
the last herb under trailer I hate when people
request stuff that we've already done use the
search bar I get mad I'm pissed damn it John
I'm not good at choosing the butt that was a
good one that is this is this a different menu
yes yes leave a message now whenever Coy wants
to see the c word now I can hit that this [__]
person in the chat is such a think that they and
then hell yeah that's I'm talking about people if
you guys are just here uh please uh leave a like
on this video thank you to all be contributing
here and uh the streams and the supers John
yeah do me a solid what you what do we do can
you check uh to see if there's anything in the
Stream I don't check the super uh stream yeah I
don't check stuff uh Roy 2192 moment of silence
thank you my friend what is this button do John
talk oh goodness it's the large robot function I
am a large robot I am a large human he really
mess with your brain I really enjoyed that I
can I can program this later to have both of you
on there I just have to do it from the computer
like all right here we go here we go Deadshot
thank you for the super he's saying Noir might
be Sam from gen V that's my theory a month later
and it's him yeah uh Sam's pretty small that is
they can augment his body I was like here we
go they can augment his body we got we got a
COI time we can take it easy while Koy does a
rift Sam small move it it's not possible move
it along no else world no no speculation for
me it's pretty small Prett small girl he's 5'4
doesn't work doesn't track does track at least
a 62 black noir man I don't buy it uh I it's a
fun Theory because I do think they're going to
be in the show but I don't think it's going to
be I think it's going to be the comic book story
line of Blackmore which is very different than
the way the show went P one which I also while
while we're ranting or while that was the pitch
for me to rant uh is I do think it's really
smart of the boys to steer away from that
comic story line and then potentially steer back
to it it's a very inventive way to make us comic
fans happy got we got one we got one oh my God
what we got one oh my God we got a humongo one
we got a hunka hunka hunka hka Super Chat yeah
what do we got it's our boy it's The Boy The
Boy hold on uh what's going on I'm making the
screen symmetrical again oh okay not leaving a
black but see the nice thing is you can just
keep want to get this limited ads on a video
that's already demed can they take away more the
beautiful thing about the a bill is that you can
keep talking and it will just cut the audio so
like yeah that's funny yeah though see I know okay
all right rard 2192 Jensen Carl and Jeffrey need
them in season 4 dude yeah that is kind of the um
the hope that people have you seen Supernatural
That's A Dope Show man yeah that's a great show
I love kpy now so I I would love to see how he
started usually the favorite show that we cover
at patreon because we don't um we don't we we uh
we're like season 13 wow and we still like really
look forward even when after like experiencing
really bad episodes we still like extremely look
forward to it's that show that you love no matter
the highs or the lows hell yeah I love that show
so much and like those guys are so Charming like
a Tik Tok of them comes across I always watch it
it's what's really impr what's really cool about
it is you know normally by that point actors are
just kind of just showing up on set right and
they're just and Jensen and and uhar Jared Jensen
and Jared they they show they they're there to
like constantly improve and it's really cool like
they they really show up such good things they
they've truly Amalgamated their experiences over
time you think that they would just kind of get
lazy and get their check but no they and they do
cons every weekend between filming like they were
they get stronger as performers every season it's
kind of nuts J knackles is always like I'm not I'm
trying to bring it back always got the Winchesters
and after Winchesters we going try and bring back
Supernatural again I'm like whoa dude somebody in
the chat just real quick uh let's give a little
round of applause SS2 for your third live stream
super all right John let's check it out all right
here we go we do got to make sure we end at a c
we do not finish the stream without doing all the
supers and such uh and the streamlabs however um
we do got to make sure we end by a certain point
because we got Doctor Who that we got to cover
doct man and uh we going to be a very extended
day that's right but thank you guys for being here
this is this was I think this this is really fun
roasted it's not fun when you put together like
you spend like okay it was going to be a few hours
putting all this together and then just keep like
blocking her copyright C or you have a chat like
we had three weeks ago or whatever when we so this
is this is way more I I think this is way more
fun yeah yeah thank you guys this this has been
a blast roasted you guys think butcher will have
to take real compound V to save his life Coy make
your time worth it uh I think they're going to be
uh dealing with the ramification of the drug like
the the oxycodone hydrocodone methodone version
of compound V in the beginning and I think by the
end there's going to be a commentary on like what
you have to do to fight soups like fighting fire
with fire so I do think at least a couple of the
boys will end up being uh permanently on compound
V by the end and I do think we're getting like a
season five where it's going to be the big battle
of power powered up folks uh so I do think a a
baseline of compound V for at least butcher maybe
more than boys that's what I'm talking about on St
boys St boys okay so let's uh the live chat would
be here sure there it is hey so whenever we're
talking about a certain subject we slide that over
we'll slide the image over move the clage over
all right I like it all right J blazing moment
of silence oh thanks for watching the hairspray
video we I really have you seen herb uh the Zack
Efron movie yeah I saw it in theaters yeah uh so I
watched it with Aaron yeah uh Alexander fun and we
did not we had no idea about it we were joking
in the intro we were like hey we don't uh like
we don't know anything about it I know normally
you might expect me to like pair with one of the
girls on the channel cuz it's musical but they've
all seen it so I'm here with Aon my my big tall
black friend here we were like joking about it
because we thought that it was uh it would not
be in any way black mood whole intro with the
commentary sudden this starts coming over like
I had no idea I did not choose you I'm so sorry
this wasn't because you're black that I chose
this movie The Story it is oh that's amazing we
just watching it going this is oh I love that so
fun we had no clue it was so oh my friend n just
played uh the lead in the hairspray on Broadway
here in La koi knows someone SE KO knows people
oh my God you just dropped a name let me pick that
up for you I said my friend n didn't say a name
drop just a friend of mine who played the leaded
hairspray they're a name drop button want to press
we got to have we got to add a little name got a
coin somebody well I'm just saying it was cool to
see the reinterpretation on Broadway after seeing
the movie in high school on the big screen every
time you do that now it's going to be time for
a so uh just ready Jess blazing J blazing uh maybe
we'll cover the Grand Theft Auto 6 let you know J
blazing moment of silence thank you so much J blaz
appreciate you Luis Santos is so as well thank you
for the momento deeno apparently blocked one of
our followers which I probably enjoyed Marvin
shouldn't have done that that's that's a suvenir
for you it's an honor to be I'm trying to get
blocked by koi right now B books B books you're so
close John new images for Godzilla multiplied by
Kong have been released how do you do that monster
math anyway you know I want to see Godzilla and
Kong's Offspring okay I appreciate the Super Chat
I appreciate the Super Chat immensely I don't uh
and because you super chat I I'm like oh we should
look at it at the same time the trailer comes out
tomorrow and I feel like the less we see the more
rewarding the trailer reaction will be don't I
want to diminish my returns at all that's how you
can tell if it's good is if you look at all the
stuff and it still works you you got to see every
single frame then watch the movie you want to
know a little thing that uh a few a lot of us can
tell when a when a reactor has already seen oh my
God it's so obvious there's a couple people think
yeah they don't want to seem like they researched
in smart beforehand some sometimes I'm like I saw
you Tweeting that you saw this at at some an hour
later at some events that you were at and now
you're that's a totally different social network
this is the first time you've seen this like
just saw you like on Twitter yeah it is pretty
obvious randoom Mando something it's funny thank
you for the first time every single live stream
they were like do you read regular chat sometimes
and I'm like yeah we were clearly using it for the
narrative every every stream someone says that
when we always clearly interacting he did the
Monster Math are you guys serious smash it was
a graveyard smash uh GTA was the first play She
Grand Theft Auto 3 was the first PlayStation uh
2 game I ever played and but I I haven't played
since San Andreas actually so I played that City
San Andreas and the I just haven't picked it up
again I was really into the N the one where you're
the Russian guy yeah I had enough exposure Grand
aut and L I used didn't really enjoy went outside
life just you just went outside your door and your
and your stars went up cop cop car and helicopters
show up out of nowhere you like all this this is
life o a background yeah okay it all right okay
lana. org Lana my dear Lana our beautiful friend
Lana just saying hi love and appreciate you guys
thank you Lana so much we appreciate you hope she
owns that website lana. yeah I hope so too all
Lana L's really sweet she's been in so many of
our she she's constantly here in her Liv she's
such like for Years Years thank you so much I
don't even stay invested in things for years
minutes I haven't played GTA V very serious
about played five I've never play new Tekken game
what's up I would love to watch Chucky season on
my own time all right Christian unpronouncable
uh Christian unpronouncable again one of our top
top contributors always here in our than so much
and we can pronounce you every time have any one
of you guys watch Stanley's lucky man uh no have
you I you know what that is it's about a superhero
who always gets lucky in the bedroom or life only
in the bed it's his x-rated I actually did have a
story idea about there might be good luck Chuck
like you know how there's Domino oh yeah we got
another first timer Diego so Domino but yeah but
the luck is just sexually hold on I'm learning how
to I I have decided in this moment I must accept
that we all interrupt each other like crazy that's
you're just now aced we've been doing this for
two years and I'm trying to just like Focus here
here weird time for that light bul other we'll
we'll mute the other mics until you're done no
no no no yes two years in what we talking about
oh luckyy but about how uh there's no reward when
you're always winning right you know like and I
think that there's got to be some weird type of
existential conflict that can occur I'd love movie
about that or a black cat movie would' be really
interesting like other people getting bad luck so
she always wins and how that like eventually gets
old because if you've got that lead up do you
even feel like you're winning yeah duh winning
that's that's in my commentary that's what I got
mad at everyone for interrupting me all right we
need another refresh we do but we got to look at
this okay we guys we let's John please Zoom it
in all right Zoom it in whoa no that's November 22
already zoomed in okay cooln refresh it refresh it
Jes got refresh it's December right it's all the
time all right here we oh oh you're on November
John I was doing that for dramatic effect G whoa
look at this guy November I want to show you guys
just how insane Chris of a like I talk with Chris
Wham off uh so and the guy's recently engaged
congratulations and I won't be I won't get um to
specific here out of respect however as a man who
has panoy Pride he is marrying a Filipino that's
what I'm talking about man you are my mom and
dad yes I am so excited man that flabbergasting
number just whams me right off I'm so excited
for you dude so excited for you play that is a
um dude Chris swam off look at this guys he has
been incredibly gener because he knows that there
was a lot of I like how he says no show it we're
gonna show it there's been there's been a lot of
there's been a lot of different things that have
occurred behind the scenes here and Chris has been
very especially during the strike season and Chris
has been extremely helpful and generous so thank
you Chris he's already been a very insanely kind
gentleman but like he already contributed like a
couple of times this amount and now heting this
amount again and soon he's going to have no money
for the wedding no I was hope for his you're going
to have to be the minister we are going to have
to bring the Rings up and can I The Flower Boy
you the yeah I'll be the ring guy if you invite
us we will go I'm just letting you know yeah
no we're there oh we're we're definitely there
that would be really fun actually I think he's
in Michigan yeah oh let's go to Detroit always
want to go to Detroit let's do a live show in
Detroit let's do a live show in Detroit Chris is
asking hey are you guys going to do anything for
Godzilla minus one well John and Andrew because
uh they're prior commitment and they're going to
react to it I'm going to go enjoy it with my wife
I have a review up in my channel and wow yeah this
time last year was at a wedding and my wedding and
uh end up getting you were just at it Greg ended
up getting hospitalized were you at the wedding
yeah but I but I had to leave the wedding cuz uh
some catering person [__] you want to know a
funny behind the scenes story real reject uh I
was supposed to be at the wedding and I got uh a
really okay so I got I went to a con and I caught
this thing called RSV which is usually only for
kids but I had really that's what it turned out
to be I had really bad covid the year before so
my immune system was tanked so I went to this
Con end up getting RSV but it it turned into um
a head trauma that almost turned into menitis so
basically uh Greg's wedding was like so important
to me and I had gotten my plane tickets John and
I were trying to figure out the moves and I
was really sick for weeks leading up to the
wedding but I was like I'm gonna go and so I go
to the doctor right before to get cleared like
literally the day of I'm sending Greg pictures
of me at the doctor and I'm like okay they just
said if I fly 70% chance of facial paralysis 80%
chance of hearing loss cuz basically my head was
so clogged if I had descended in the plane it
could have ruptured my eard drum causing facial
paralysis and I was like should I come do you
that seems like a thing that is dangerous and
so like the next day I'm like Greg I'm so sorry
and I couldn't get in touch with Greg it's his
wedding I don't expect to get in touch with Greg
but then the following day he's like hey man I'm
in the hospital and I was like what like we were
avoiding all hospitalization by me not coming to
this wedding and so I find out after me being
in and out of doctors and hospitals that Greg
uh has been uh poison at his own wedding and it
was very dark last year this time and and so I'm
going to go enjoy one of the rare occasions where
I'm going to go enjoy a movie in the theaters and
I'm not going to feel pressured to uh make a video
about it a I will give my opinion casually and
periodically on it I'm sure in a future stream
it's exceptional and I'm glad everybody's love
and as much as I know like yeah it'll get views
just it's good to see you'll catch my opinion I'm
I want to just watch a movie with my wife do that
what yeah Aisha Kenya a live show in Texas would
be so dope if we could collab with Double Toasted
all righty I thought I to go to Austin for like
more than a more than a day uh Chris Chris whof
is also saying LOL looks like I wasn't the only
one excited about GZ1 minus one Godzilla minus one
is exceptional I have heard some amaz like some
fascinating feedback favorite monster movie of
all time I'm so excited I've heard that man I've
heard that people love this [__] people are like
this is like everything I wanted from a monster
movie but also like this is Oscar so when I saw
it I saw it like I said in a void by myself and
because I had to screen it before the premiere
and then at the premiere I was so curious how
the audience would react and I had the cool thing
where at the end I got to sit on the stage waiting
for the movie to end to do the Q&A and I got to
watch the audience watch the movie and it was
so beautiful to see people laughing at the same
time and crying and it was uh like two3 American
one3 Japanese audience and it was so cool to see
this big big emotion and then like other people
getting comfortable giving big emotion and like
the shared cultural conscious it was beautiful
man I love that movie so much all for you Chris
Wham off my sexy sexy friend all John refesh I'll
be looking here hey Bucky Chris Bucky Barnes in
the chat of course thank you for being want live
show too everybody gets a live show everybody is
Doctor Who already out uh uh I thought it was out
thought was 11:30 I thought it was out Christmas
no matter started airing oh there's a Christmas
special yeah there is a Christmas okay that's
what I I thought you were talking about yeah
all righty let's say let's all righty see next
X going show up in we got this one right yeah
we did these moments we're way there we're way
we're way we're way down John right there John
so far down right there there Black Phillip philli
plus raising their subscription price so you don't
share passwords we get Winterfell thank you though
for being here we get Winterfell and the Starks in
season 2 surprise do we really damn we get the
Starks coming to season two exting I'm glad they
waited on that that's usually what the sophomore
seasons do with these shows huh they add in more
that's when they go like all right now let's get
you some things you really the H gave you just
this one thing and now we're going to spray all
the stuff you Rec sequel sequel we got to let you
realize that'll probably come into the what have
I done this time oh sorry the Hot D we're back
keep track of everything all the variabl learning
slow we can't help each other out never my job
singular I got to put the stream I'm putting the
stream on my back all right so leave a like for
me um but yeah oh man I can't wait for that dude
and they're all going to be played by Shawn Bean
everyone all the living ones he won't die anymore
and we'll be like yeah there are hundreds of years
until he's supposed to die so like at least he's
got plot armor that's true dies every EP damn it
Sean I want to make a they like people make meta
things about Nick Cage I want to make a meta sha
Bean movie about him constantly dying can we make
a sha Bean movie where he's the only Immortal the
actor will live past all of us and that's why he
dies in movies yeah he's so comfortable dying he
lives forever guys guys we got an insanely kind
super generous Super Chat here stupid swi thank
you stupid sandwich so much hey everyone massive
shout out to Greg Coy and John along with the rest
of the reject Nation uh thank you for so shout out
to you stupid sandwich and thank you to everyone
who's been embracing as we've been expanding
thanks John for doing that sorry thank you to
everyone who's been embracing uh the expansion
of the amount of hosts that we have here on the
channel it's been uh it helps out for us to have
a more variety and at the same time uh you know
it's not easy introducing a bunch of people on
as regulars and I think everyone's been just
very very kind and welcoming uh I just wanted to
use this soap box to encourage everyone to see
Godzilla minus one M it is so cool you know I know
Godzilla is like it's such a massive franchise at
the end of the day it is an international movie
and to see how it is taking off so much here in
the states and now people are like it's a must see
in the theaters and like Godzilla is so popular
out here already but for it to be one from Japan
that everyone you must see this in the theaters
and you're seeing just the amount of support
around it is making me Chomp at the bed I can't
wait for you to watch it on the TV John hly the
best movie I have seen theater since Enemy at the
gates haven't seen Enemy at the gates I haven't
either this this is Sniper movie I haven't seen
the one with Jude Law I think it's the moment
with you like let's all react to Enemy at the
gates together that's what we're doing here on the
stream guys guys let's throw it onemy at the gates
it has gotten to the point I mean like I will
want to see Godzilla minus one in the theater at
some point in my life but like we live in a place
where that's possible and we've gotten to a point
now where I'm no longer like bummed to save these
things for reactions depending like sawx is like
one of the movies been looking forward to so much
this year but I was also like I'm excited to do
fun to share I'm excited to share that on screen
so like so yeah Godzilla minus one I'm I'm cool
that's good I'm I cannot wait and and that's the
thing is like I love that the American Godzilla
iterations especially with the monster verse
are very popular but I love that like it's a
shared property now and even Shin Godzilla seemed
to be like kind of commenting on directly on that
but I love that Japan like the you know the OG
Godzilla or you know uh Pro progenitors yeah
uh like can always come in with a showstopper
and like the entire world gathers around it
and and I love that so all righty guys beautiful
beautiful now normally we we don't end the stream
without reading all the super chats but we have
to like just because we got to stay on schedule
today for such a crazy schedule uh John we should
probably close them let's no we're going to do is
we're we're going to finish we are going to read
everyone that's already come in um but yeah we
should be able to we have to stop from allowing
we're only allowing stickers at this moment
because yeah we just want to make sure we end
Tamil Godzilla minus one is my favorite Godzilla
movie Shin Godzilla is my second Godzilla 1954 is
my third uh and then 199 and then Godzilla uh king
of the monsters is my fourth Cody really yeah I
like K the monsters quite a bit got a still track
guys Okay C Bishop you guys watch other react
three people just just under the wire go you got
your just under the wire to get it right before
John uh candit Cody Bishop do you guys watch
other react channels or YouTubers uh yeah CO's Coy
only watches nerd roic videos yeah I go to sleep
that's why I wake up happy to get on Twitter uh
Cody Bishop yeah man I mean uh God I gotta just
I mean the my obvious go-to ones Mr Sunday movies
uh Double Toasted um joh Chris Duckman I watch the
lawyer I do watch I do watch legal eagle legal
eagle that's the one watch myne um I love Cosa
variety hour I I like YMS and God red letter media
red letter media yeah there's a great hi top films
3C films spoilers C wonders screen Crush Double
Toasted um God there's a lot of people Patrick H
Williams is great one Patrick H Williams is great
um what else is there I listen to AR expert and M
God I feel like there's just so many like payer
weight breakfast all day uh a lot of audio books
on finance I mean I I do not I I don't want to
start listing off other other react channels
fantano because what ends up happening is I end
up not listing off someone right cuz I I I know
so many of the reaction like the shadow there's
there's been a like these big group Zoom calls
with like a but so I know so many of them and
and I and I what I hate doing is when I list off
reaction like oh [__] I should have said that so
there's there's a lot of reaction Channel A lot of
them are great and you guys are Len you guys are
listenting to several of them in the chat right
now and uh I really appreciate you guys listen
them off but yeah list list off in the chat some
react channels going show them I'm so love their
names will pop up on screen but I don't want to
the only thing I watch on YouTube is this Little
Indie Channel called hot ones watchepisode last
night Sterling K Brown was exceptional enjoy that
interview for people who are tuning in we already
covered the trailers now we're just doing an open
Q&A de eyes uh John you turn it off I turned them
off all right so let's just make sure all you
can send his stickers now we're make sure we're
on track we're going to refresh I need to watch
some more uh like female content creators though
I feel like I do you know there's this uh there's
this one movie she she doesn't do reactions uh
she doesn't have a huge channel oh what is her
name her Pops I also have a PR um Billy binges
is great okay I just shouted Out Billy binges
is really funny I like merse a lot too um let
me see here you guys are just making up words
no merse they're two react channels melv verse
uhuh a one too is it Mel Gibson or Mel Brooks Sean
Sean C what is her name she's she is a Roxy strier
no no no no always Lola hear is a great film
always Lola this weekend Godzilla minus one and
always always back to back double beat support
boom do what is her name she I God damn she's a
great all she she just sits in her living room
she does these reviews and she and she's such
a articulate speaker like there's this dude I
say oh I know who you're talking about I think
Awkward Ashley is she an Asian woman oh just name
chat nerdy no I mean yeah no there there is a I
don't remember names no there's a different girl
no okay I know who you're talking about but yeah
I'll watch her too yeah I just kind of see their
thumbs and I go oh yeah yeah let me watch it but
I constantly forget the names of everyone yeah
unless I've been watching you for years I'm GNA
forget your name all right anyway damn Richie
love lace on Tik Tok eyes do eyes thank you so
much 2023 has been a lot and this channel makes
every day a little brighter much love to you
guys oh thank you so much you make life a lot
rter thank you thank you SS2 stuck inside with
a cold appreciate y'all a lot I'm sorry that you
have a cold I thought I was getting sick yesterday
I you just weren't sleeping I started Downing a
lot of vitamins and I feel um I don't feel sick
just a little tired that's but I feel good there's
there's an omn media shout out in the chat go go
give him some love I'm sorry you feel sick buddy
but thank you for being here hopefully we can
keep you company right now hopefully we're like
chicken soup for your souls struggle nation's a
great name that's fun fasting struggle Nation
I'm glad you guys like my uh previous comment
about Greg being W always as it should be lmf
hey yo lmow I know that band laughing my wait
laughing my ass off wasn't sure how it would be
taken seriously though you guys are amazing I
mean thanks out of the three of us only Ko's
the one who can't take a joke tune in to two
weeks ago's live stream oh that was a good one
that was a little spicy I was leaving all those
comments is do is Doctor Who already out cuz we're
going to get on it we're going to live react to it
here on on the live stream oh man I love liquid
IV good call Bucky Barnes liquid I drink one of
those every morning and I try to do a second
one every night it's very expensive hobby but
it keeps me hydrating CU I don't drink enough
water we got a reset for uh mean we we have we
just have to be on track with our schedule today
Deadshot so we're probably not going to be able
to cover that MK1 trailer alashia Queen that's her
name that's that lady's name that's the Asian the
Asian girl you're talking about yeah yeah she's
great what is that one girl's name what did she
review [__] what did she talk about I'll find
it later all right all right fine but no thank
you fasty and yeah we can take a joke most of the
time on camera we can take a joke yeah it's not a
man of the Jedi is it I do watch am man of the
Jedi she's great yeah she's fun very creative
Michael rigs Michael rigs Fallout TV show should
be Parts Evil Dead idiocracy ex mocking us space
Odyssey and Duke Nukem that is a kind of a oh my
God I love those things Fallout does feel like a
strong amalgamation of a bunch of different things
and and I guess the question is is I I feel like
understanding what the unique because it's really
easy to look at a trailer for something that is
an adaptation and go kind of reminds me of this
kind of reminds me of that um but no Alejandra
to answer your question in the chat right now we
haven't played I mean John's played Fallout Cory
and I haven't played Fallout and looks Wicked fun
and you know the chat kind of goes back and forth
yes Chris swam off Natalie gold that's her name uh
no Natalie gold is a is is like one of top movie
reactors oh also shouts out to great one shouts
out to De is always watching de is always watching
here um but the what are we talking about Fallout
uniqueness us not knowing it yeah I don't really I
I I just want to I kind of want to deep focused
lens you got it yes yes that's who that's who
it was deep focus lens yes she's great she's like
there's not crazy production goes into her videos
but just she could write a book or some [__]
like she's so good at freaky now like I'll just
listen to her [__] while she's talking I don't
I don't even have to watch the video and it is she
seriously if you want like a great reviewer deep
focused lens she is excellent excellent reviewer
woo um also great last name absolute vodka way you
AA Aisha Kenya aishaa happy holidays guys aside
from YouTube what are your personal goals for 2024
is there anything we can do to help support those
goals pulling up my 2024 goals oh my oh my God I
thought I thought Cole was Coy was just checking
out progressively more from this stream no
he's just pulling up his document I wanna I
want Jesus I want to touch 159 lbs I'm currently
168 I want to touch my toes I've never done that
since I was a baby I want to hit 10% body fat
I want to average 13% body fat I want to take
four trips three East Coast one international I
want to do five cons minimum I want 150 miles I
want to run do 250 workouts 365 days I want to
try aditt fasting for at least a month I want
to try cold therapy for at least a month I want
to try cardio Focus for a month I want to try
no process foods month I want to experience 12
new restaurants at least one a month I want to
experience one new country minimum next month
I want to experience one new thing for my job
I want to get 250,000 across social media I want
to do an 8 minute mile I want to do a 26.2 mile
distance want to do a marathon basically 225
on my bench again more regularly 100 100 curl
regularly one push-up per squat per day of that
year are my goals next year I'm G get them I got
24 goals for 2024 I didn't read my four financial
goals because that's personal but you got 20 I did
read um that is um no that's amazing that's what
I want those are 20 of my 2024 goals I got 24 of
them I didn't read the finance ones the person
got something against my goals Greg got something
against my goals I read your Finance goals that's
some really impressive you guys just break it
down into increments so yeah there's four there
there's different there's four I think you have
enough goals for all three of us no look it's
it's sections of four and they're all different
styles of goal I think important need organize my
goals the way you do uh my goals are um they're
script related and uh they're already on track
for something awesome and I got a couple emails
about it um just this week dude congratulations
it's great way to start next year momentum the
way to get to do next year you start now a lot
of people wait till till January but you start
now like I'm always about getting had it's always
next year I wrote those out December 1st like that
is uh that's what I do and I and I started my 2024
calendar yesterday uh I scroll the wrong way let's
just read the skip follow TV show should be Parts
Evil Dead ocracy ex space let go back is John is
there another movie you would include onto this
list uh cuz I said Westworld part of it versus
Aliens I said Westworld little bit of Mad Max uh I
haven't seen the Creator but I'm going to say the
Creator I haven't seen the Creator either but the
Creator kind of yeah sort of yeah contribute if
the Creator was set in a desert rather than all of
East Asia say something to this um um haven't seen
Idiocracy oh what oh damn dog Ian what's part Evil
Dead I didn't get Evil Dead I mean other than the
guess Goin looks like kind I guess there there's
a bit of zann in there there's a little sprinkling
of I'll think of more uh uh uh influences here
metad Del taera saying right here we guys sup
guys love your content saw koi and KK kville a
few weeks ago and wanted to say hi but you had
company oh K Town my bad I misread it yeah yeah I
thought oh I I heard about in L should be confused
there miss my chance but hopefully another time
dude oh my God if if you recognize Coy he would
love that so please go say hi to your face be like
as long as it's attention big lior Coy is going
to be happy to see in the bathroom so many people
try to say hi in the bathroom and it's never like
there's no way to handle it there's no polite way
to be like hold on let's just leave this bathroom
that's how you claim I just move it over and then
I go now you'll remember me yeah you just turn
directly to face them peeing yeah dude you got to
do an idiocracy unless I'm eating or peeing say hi
guys look at the the three women who are always
in the chat here beautiful beautiful appreciate
you also Michelle watches my channel which makes
me so happy thank you Michelle trying to grow it
got almost 22,000 guys she watches your channel
sorry Michelle it's time to now we got to ban you
sorry about that that s only one of us at a time
where's your Allegiance I love I love Korea Town
and as long as I'm not eating or peeing please say
hi Dakota Jones Dakota again another one I love
seeing the familiar faces it's like a sophomore
season of any show uh saying is Marie gonna give
homelander brain bleeding do you Coy do you think
do you think Marie is GNA show up in boy season 4
uh I think briefly I think they'll be setting up
where basically genv season 2 goes throughout the
boys so I think there's going to be like a not
even a b plot but like a C or D plot with some
of those characters but I think it'd be a little
distracting I liked how gen V didn't have too much
of the boys in it I think likewise if you make
homelander too related to gen V it'll kind of
um Sully both shows so I don't think they'll be
directly related but I think it'll be like a CD
plot hell I love CD plots compact disc plot I've
never seen Children of Men Louis Santos uh we
appreciate the Super Chat immensely we did say
earlier in the Stream though that we are going
to be avoiding the Jack Reacher trailer yes and
I know it sounds silly but we're we're going to
watch it in just a couple of weeks uh they're
premiering three episodes and I'm just like
well we already didn't see the first trailer so
we might as well just go and like we don't know
what's going to happen let's see we're already
hyped it's going to come out in a few weeks and
then and the less we know I think the better
of an experience it'll be because we we have
enough time to forget about what we saw in this
house of the Dragon trailer yes it was very V we
have enough time to forget about what we saw
in this Boys trailer cuz that that's usually
what happens for for us we watch a trailer this
early in advance is that I will completely forget
at least on mine I'll be like I don't remember
at all what happened uh all righty cool thanks
Jason thank you Louis Santos thanks for watching
the the first Blood video appreciate that I loved
that that was great a nice surprise excited for
second blood yeah it's really cool that you guys
were able to pretend that you hadn't seen First
Blood com really hard so many of the comments are
so funny like they've obviously seen this and
I was like we get stuff wrong that that become
my favorite comment is like half the movies we
do now people get in there and they're like no
there's just no way you didn't see this this
such a weird activity to do there's a reason
why uh there's a bigger variety of people who
come on the channel now because we've seen of
course like I've most of us have like I literally
have to come up with like a giant list of movies
based off recommendations or a variety of other
things yeah and then it becomes like email blast
and then trying sort out and then seeing like
there's like a whole checklist and the whole
questionnaire comes back to like tell me which
ones you have seen and which ones you haven't
seen then it becomes about a signing there's
this whole process that is very intricate to
make sure but there's always someone to be like
oh they haven't seen that be like they've totally
seen it when there's there's an entire process to
make John hasn't watched like five of my top 20
movies MJ I have not seen Saturday Night Fever I
don't know if quite has I've not either dude John
hasn't seen Fight Club Diego first time making it
to a stream watching your videos throughout the
years have helped me get through when times were
tough so thank you yeah whatever moving on from
the grave interesting thank you so much Diego you
know it's kind of crazy that we have been doing
this for several years all this time it doesn't
feel like several years and yet it somehow does
that's how time works I'm still in the same Panic
oh my God survive mode no matter how long we've
been doing this Panic is here Tera just yesterday
was like How come every time I come over it's oh
my God there's an emergency I don't got time to
talk we got to get to this Hurry Up This is your
Perpetual existence that's how we all arrived that
is I'm sorry I'm so sorry Terra that's the doorway
come through that doorway you're coming into that
for Tera you're going to change that but not for
any of the rest no we have to live it um let
me uh I've seen prisoners JN and I saw pris in
theaters that was one of the first movies you ever
reviewed it's my favorite Jake Gyllenhaal Michelle
you haven't seen prison no I love prisoners
my fav it's Michelle supporter of the koi jro
YouTube channel Michelle that Super Chat is just
for Koy love you Michelle you're always up here uh
Charlie 836 any update on Arcane season 2 we got
the download for you guys we've been working hard
on it all right and production is going great
Greg has been drawing all the animation Coy's
been writing the scripts and I've been doing the
voiceover this season it stick figures definitely
we just figured we can get the show done faster
you care more about the writing then you do the
anime figures they don't have to move even they
just stand there and we do let the dialog talk a
me flipping a book yep all my dialogue involves
the CW I hope you're ready there it is Char 836
Spidey Sensei 72 this is Roxy strier ghost account
yes Ron Joy yo Char 836 I love your your profile
pick man that is so sexy yeah buddy um Spidey
Sensei 72 just a reminder go watch always Lola
and help support Roxy's new movie this weekend it
so you know what I saw on this was crazy 100% Rond
is it de yeah yeah yeah and guys um I bought the
movie already Yes and um the we we were we were
looking up we John and I watched eza and we were
looking up reviews on while we were reviewing it
and then on the most popular section like I said
for most popular on ronto Manas and I don't think
it's like specifically algorithm generated like I
I'm pretty sure it's like what is currently just
really popular right now always Lola was was there
I was like damn that's nuts oh that's so exciting
good for her man nuts beautiful go Roxy I got well
deserved fake account and talk [__] about her
yeah one star I'm like if we bring her down then
that will make her commitment here last long'll
strength her she feels like she needs to fill the
void with reaction starts getting more acting work
and she can't be here as much so if I talk [__]
about her yeah humble her make her look make make
make casting directors think that people don't
like her that way she's not on the I started a
bunch of dummy accounts like to pretend to be
casting directors commenting on the video what
I've learned about leading the channel is you got
to tear people down right down in order to keep
them around it's like a horse you just reel it in
let them go you reel them back in the movie always
Lola is streaming right now there may be some
screenings around if you it's video on demand
so you got to rent or purchase it so uh yeah Diego
Diego Diego sorry Ike it's off topic but have you
three ever consider reacting to Young Justice or
Harley Quinn would love to hear your thoughts on
those interpretations of the characters top tier
shows uh young justice has sometimes come up in
the conversation committing to a show that is not
performing well really [__] you in the algorithm
not going to lie in the like rebounding from Scott
it's it's what sucks is a lot of times it's just
show we love like rebounding from Scott Pilgrim
sad John and I did not love Witcher season 3 at
all and no that was one of the most disheartening
experiences when you're like we're not even liking
this show we're committed to finishing it and
it's getting shitty ass views at the same time
so I would much rather be watching a certain
other show we will not algorithm and then Scott
Von versus the world I mean takes off that was
a bummer because it didn't do well but on on the
channel however we really love this show and it
is one of those disheartening effects when you're
like man but whenever we upload we know it's
affecting us in the algorithm and now we got
to bounce back it's drowning other things a weird
thing so that's the that's the scarier part about
committing to a show because it's got to be it's
got to be good you got to be like we got to lot we
got to know we're very interested in it even if
we don't like it we got to know we are at least
very interested in watching it m because that's
what that's what really matters and and then and
secondly hopefully does well yeah [__] it's it's
like a movie might not do well but it's a movie
two hours and you're like and it has a different
chance of growing yeah whereas a show has a very
limited shelf life Santiago heck Mt is also good
shouts out to master tainment Mt is a g I love his
work on heavy spoilers a lot I think he's amazing
great um uh yeah okay sorry to answer the question
um I've seen the first two seasons of of Harley
Quinn I've seen the first three there's a fourth
coming out now or the fourth greit have you seen
any Harley seen z% of Harley Quin great so good
I've heard I haven't seen the the Valentine's
Day special though oh I yeah behind on Harley
Quinn but no it's a John it's so good it's it's
like what tone you want from an R-rated cartoon
comedy yeah yeah all right I'm excited one of
these days it's like like birds of prey but
Everyone likes this one instead yeah we like our
women two dimensional and the kit I love birds
of prey I love birds of pre it's in my top five
VC and Michelle I appreciate that you loved the
Scott Pilgrim coverage it was all for you it was
all for you Michelle oh my god did we reach the
top did we reach it okay cuz yeah what time is it
we got a all right yeah yeah yeah sweet I'm always
into something all right cool we did it gu let me
just make sure we got everything here we'll do a
couple quick sound offs then we're do it we'll
get to rock and yeah we're caught up we've done
it sweet sauce John removes this thing and then we
talk to people all right be rid of the thing are
these trailers coming out La ComiCon uh no they're
coming out of Brazil yeah Brazil ComicCon which is
why we are covering a Brazilian film which is why
none of us are at La comic sometimes I put out on
the list of movies I put out a foreign film
on there and I'm like I know every everyone's
going to tell me they haven't seen it cuz they all
city of God no not city city of God is a Brazilian
film actually I thought that was the reference
I haven't se now would have been the time to do
City that's been on the list for months I have
not seen it I'll put you and Aaron on there cool
I for not obvious reasons I like Aaron uh nope
this is just going to be a stream it's get two
white dudes watching the Brazilian movie hey uh
let's uh so guys uh thank you so much for being
here uh we got to set up and get re quainted we
have I mean all three I think all three of us
have seen children men I have not seen children of
men that was the main talking point in my Creator
review is I reference children of it's been on my
list forever I've mentioned this multiple times
he hasn't seen Fight Club that's going to vex me
until he SE seen Children of Men I want to watch
Fight Club with you and I'll be my 17th time
reaction to your first time reac you know what
you should do whoever we should I'll pair up with
somebody to react but we'll have you sitting just
facing me just watching you watch Fight Club yeah
I want my favorite movie of all time we we'll put
you in the corner in a separate box seems like
for a solo John video the ones that do the best
are if they're like an animated movie sure that's
fine yeah I mean I'm nothing has to happen I'm
just saying I've not seen children of mint and I
would love to see animated children of soon anyway
guys look we got to end this stream but thank you
guys so much uh you made this experience way more
enjoyable so I'm so sorry pet have you seen Peter
Griffin is in fortnite that's hilarious it was one
of those uh disgusting film posts where you see it
and it just said uh fortnite is is putting Peter
Griffin in the game it releases December 5th and
everyone has been meming it because it's one of
those where you're like this is disusing no it's
just the regular disgusting film so people have
been putting all sorts of other meme characters
in so I'm happy that's taken uh random I've read
every Chuck pic book but is most recent too
big Chuck pic fan I've read Fight Club many
times and I've read books about Fight Club like
philosophical studies and stuff that's amazing
fought in a club I am putting uh kash's ending
this I got to end this guys I got to end it but
so thank you Jason and fasty for keeping us on
track love you guys uh yeah we got a lot coming
out this week keep a look out tomorrow will not be
a live stream for Godzilla vers konggo will just
be a regular trailer reaction uh but I'm excited
for it Charlie 836 Joe the man Michelle every
there's a lot of people who come thank you for
the I want to shout out Chris again for massive
generous Super Chat and uh I want to get the
right name St sorry I want to get your name right
shout out the big one where's that every
everyone who contributed thank you because
yeah this stream got demonetized immediately
instantly so thank you guys and stupid sandwich
thank you so much for another very generous
Super Chat um but yeah guys uh this is over
that's it unless there's anything else we
should play nope no no no that it should
have been mid all right Bucky thanks
for holding it down see you guys John
close us out I've been holding in bathroom
for 30 minutes he's got a pie he's leaving